snaking their way along oxford street
many thousands of protesters a march
that spanned almost the entire length
of the capital's main shopping street
this was a noisy affair real anger here
at what they see
as the great covet conspiracy
most certainly won't share those views
but the people here
believe they speak for a huge chunk of
the population
railing against continued covert
restrictions
against the prospect of so-called covet
passports
and even against the wearing of face
masks
among the protesters others who even
believe the vaccine program
is unnecessary in being driven by the
big
pharmaceutical companies i think we've
been taken over
by uh as well as becoming a totalitarian
state which is based on very bad science
in fact full science and there's a fraud
behind a lot of it already we're being
limited with testing
you're not able to get medical treatment
if you say no to testing
some people literally do not have the
ability to be tested they have health
conditions
it's just limited this is like being in
a nazi state and there's somebody who's
jewish
yes of course we are we're not we're in
a prison here people don't even realize
we're in a prison
there will be many who view these images
with alarm
angry at those they believe are ignorant
and irresponsible
but those here believe it's others who
are blind to the reality of the
situation
there are multiple viewpoints here many
different concerns
but the one thing that unites everyone
is the unshakeable belief
that the government is slowly eroding
their basic freedoms
and that suspicion of the media of big
corporations
of the state was shared at
demonstrations in other parts of the
country
there's no doubt many of the families of
the countless thousands
who've died from covid will be
understandably outraged at these scenes
but the people here are unapologetic and
planned to keep up their protests
mark white sky news central london